also zunächst mal wir sind nicht
vollständig vor gericht gescheitert und
das ist in der demokratie einem
rechtsstaat auch normal dass man gegen
auflagen klagen kann wenn man die
gerichtsurteile vor allem das urteil des
verwaltungsgerichtes zusammenfassen
wollte sind neuen seiten begründen aber
wenn man sie kurz zusammenfassen wollte
sagt diese sagt des gerichts urteil
man muss dem veranstalter eine zweite
chance geben es reicht nicht aus sich
auf die erfahrungen des ersten august zu
berufen derselbe veranstalter ja
mindestabständen mund nasenschutz nicht
eingehalten hat sondern man muss ihm
eine zweite chance geben
er hat ja einen hygieneplan vorgelegt
und versichert dass er die
abstandsregelung durchsetzen möchte ja
die zweite chance hat da heute gehabt
und erwartungsgemäß ist der heutige
vormittag ebenso verlaufen dass die
abstandsregelung eben nicht eingehalten
werden konnten
die legende dass deshalb mehr menschen
nach berlin gekommen sind es zahlenmäßig
jedenfalls erstmal so nicht zu belegen
ich sage deutlich die situation hat sich
leider erwartungsgemäß so entwickelt wie
es von der polizei berlin vorhergesagt
worden ist und dass es zunächst mal zu
dieser zweiten chance kam
es folge des gerichtsurteils aber sie
haben dann eben aus der entwicklung des
heutigen tages auch das problem gesehen
wenn sich erst mal tausende menschen
versammelt haben und dann ganz bewusst
sagen sie halten abstandsregelung eben
nicht einmal das ziel der veranstaltung
ist dauert es eben viele viele stunden
dass man das unter rechtsstaatlichen
gesichtspunkten geräumt hat und in
dieser ganzen zeit geben eine vielzahl
von infektions möglichkeiten ich hoffe
dass die zahl der erkannten durch den
heutigen tag nicht wesentlich steigt
aber das sind risiken die ich gerne
vermieden hatte und auch diese
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzung von
rechtsextremisten geht es an dieser
stelle mütchen kühlen wollen hätte ich
gerne vermieden
gekommen